in this video we'll talk about the
subtypes of T cells
now broadly T cells can be classified
into two subgroups one is CD4 positive T
helper cells another is cd8 positive
cytotoxic T cells
now that these two type of cells differ
on basis of their functions and
structures
so the helper T cells help other immune
cell types to perform their functions so
they coordinate with many cell types
whereas the cytotoxic T cells are like
cold blood killers they directly kill
the cells which is infected by virus or
let's say it's a tumor infected cell
now mostly T helper cells do their job
by secreting cytokines which are like
alarming molecules they further engage
macrophage dendritic cell and many other
immune cells and attract them to fight
together whereas cytotoxic T cells fight
by themselves they have cytotoxic
granules which has enzymes like perforin
and granzyme which lead to apoptosis of
the target cell in this video we are
going to talk about both these cell
types they are subtypes and how it is
functionally relevant
so T helper cells are generally produced
in the bone marrow eventually they
mature in the thymus and at the end of
the thymic training they become naive
tea helper cells but these naive tea
helper cells need to be activated by
antigen presenting cells such as a
dendritic cell
after the T Cell Activation
T cell would interact with other cell
types or it will differentiate into
different subtypes
now antigen presenting cell and T Cell
interaction is crucial for the
activation process I have a different
video which describes the T Cell
Activation process in bit more details
if you want this video click on the I
button
now T helper cell once get activated can
also activate B cells so it interacts
with the B cell
and eventually gives rise to the signal
that triggers the B Cell Activation
b-cell eventually form the plasma cells
there are many changes happening in the
B cells like class switching isotype
switching and Affinity maturation of the
antibodies eventually these plasma cell
would secrete specific type of antibody
and thereby participate in the humeral
immune response so indirectly th cell
activates B cell as well
now there are several subtypes of T
helper cells and with the advancement of
Technology there are new and new
subtypes coming into picture
so T helper cell can give rise to th1
type of cells which play specific role
against virus
now there are also
that means that particular cell triggers
inflammatory response there are also
subtypes known as
D regulatory cells which kind of works
like an immune homeostat
it kind of negatively regulates many
immune system and prevents the risk of
autoimmunity
both the inflammation promoting T cell
subtypes and Regulatory T cells are
important for our body's immune
homeostasis in a moment it would be bit
more clear when we talk about some
disease which is a cause of this
dysregulation of homeostasis
summarize how the T cell
activation or subtype specification
happens we have to go back to the bone
marrow because in the bone marrow there
are hematopoietic pluripotent stem cells
which eventually give rise to the T Cell
precursor
T Cell precursor gets into the
bloodstream go to the thymus and in the
thymus it undergoes very stringent
training
and there are positive and negative
selection that is happening in the
thymus at any point of time you feel
like a detailed explanation on these
topics you can click on the I button
now after the thymic training T cells
interact with the dendritic cells or any
other antigen presenting cells
and this kind of interaction which
happens in the lymph node helps in T
Cell subtype specification or subtype
differentiation happens after these kind
of specific interactions so specific
cytokines and other chemical molecules
triggered this kind of T cell
differentiation majority so T Cell birth
T cell differentiation and T Cell
lineage commitment are three important
process in the entire
immune response
now let's talk about few of the subtypes
th1 th17 t-reg and th2 cells so the th
one cells enhances the APC activity it
enhances T cytotoxic Cell Activation
protects against intracellular pathogen
but it is also responsible for
hypersensitivity and autoimmune
responses the key cytokines that are
secreted by these cells are interferon
gamma and tnf
on the other hand side th2 cells secrete
cytokines like il4 il5 and il-13
H2 cells participate in protection
against extracellular pathogens
especially it helps in ige mediated
response and it is involved in allergic
responses
deregulatory cell secretes
interleukin-10 and TGF beta
it inhibits inflammatory responses
maintains the immune homeostasis th17 on
other hand side is also a
pro-inflammatory T Cell let's say
because it secretes cytokines like
il-17a17f and il-22 th17 cells specially
protects us against fungal and bacterial
infection also it has been implicated in
many autoimmune diseases and
inflammatory diseases
now let's talk about how different types
of T cells are generated
so it all depends on the types of
pathogen that the body encountered the
types of polarizing cytokine that can
change the fit and the master
transcription factor that can regulate
different gene expression module okay at
this point it might not be clear but let
me clarify this is a th cell or this
state is known as th0 so it's a starting
point at this particular point of time
this cell has the possibility to become
different different terminal terminal
differentiated cells such as th1 cell
th17 t-reg or th2
now there are external influence which
triggers this terminal fate the external
influences include polarizing cytokine
for example in order for a th cell to be
differentiated into a t regulatory cell
il2 and TGF beta cytokines are important
whereas interferon gamma and
interleukin-12 triggers the
differentiation of th1 subtype now all
these external influence coordinate with
internal signaling modules there are
Master transcription factors which
triggers this kind of fit
for th1 the master transcriptional
regulator is Tibet
for th17 it is raw gamma
40 regulatory cells it is Fox P3 whereas
Gata 3 is the master regulator for th2
Subs type of cells each of these Master
Regulators trigger specific and unique
gene expression modules and these gene
expression modules eventually leads to
the terminally differentiated fate so
this kind of give you an idea how
different
subtypes of T cells are actually
generated so this talks about the T cell
differentiation as well
now these days with the advancement of
single cell RNA sequencing there are
specific Ways by which scientists can
understand how different subtypes of
cells and subpopulations of cells can be
discriminated with the help of
transcriptome analysis
now let me give you a quick model that
how different subtypes of T cell can be
formed based on the type of infection
let's say there is a viral infection in
the body so obviously there are specific
tailors that can recognize viral RNA or
genetic material and that would lead to
a specific cytokine production in this
case the cytokine is il-12
il-12 receptors are present in th
zero cells or t helper cells
so there are MHC and TCR related
interaction there is cd80 cd86 and cd28
interactions which are crucial for T
Cell Activation but alongside that the
polarizing cytokine il-12 leads to the
activation of t-bed gene or Tibet is the
master regulator which is getting
upregulated in this process and this
would drive the cellular fate towards
th1 cell
now in contrast when there is a helmint
infection
there are different receptors or pattern
recognition receptors which would
recognize this infection this would
ultimately lead to the production of
interleukin-4
interleukin form mediated signaling
would activate different stats and lead
to activation of a different Gene such
as a Tibet
so here we can see that there are
different kind of ah
interrelated signaling Pathways which
can antagonize each other for example
il-12 mediated signaling and il-4
mediated signaling are each important
for th1 cellular fed specification or
th2 cellular fat specification but each
case that the particular modulator of
transcription is different like stat 4
for the th1 cell stat five or six for
th2 cells
the master regulator is different for
both these cells T bit is the master
regulator for th1 differentiation gutter
3 is the master regulator for th2's fit
and each of the target genes or the
cytokines that they give rise to
actually antagonize each other and
suppress their fate so this is kind of
like a mutual suppression going on
between these two sulphates like if a
cell becomes th1 it would do anything to
suppress the th2 fit and vice versa that
means if a cell gets th2 fat it would do
anything to suppress the th1 Fate
now let's talk about th17 cells which
are generated when naive T cells are
activated in presence of il-6 and TGF
beta so th17 cells are really important
because they help us or help our body
to recognize fungal infections
so when the fungus infection affects us
there are antigen presenting cells which
recognize fungal presence with the help
of specific pattern recognition
receptors that triggers the secretion of
il-6 and TGF beta that produces th17
cells
now the tlr2 is the key thing a key
particular pattern recognition receptor
against the fungal infection
now th17 cells are characterized by
their secretion ability of il-17 th17
cells are developmentally different from
th1 and th2 sublineages so th cells get
polarizing cytokine upregulates raw
gamma and thereby become the th17
subpopulations
th17 differentiation is controlled by a
master transcription factor which is
which is a raw gamma that we understood
and this is triggered by the activation
of TGF betan interleukin-6
now there are evidences which suggest
that raw gamma is the master regulator
because the mouse which is lacking raw
gamma doesn't have that much of
th17 cells and they are very susceptible
to fungal infection
now raw gamma mice have reduced
sensitivity towards autoimmune
Encephalitis that means it is kind of
like resistant towards autoimmune
disease that highlights the
importance of this particular T cell
subtype in terms of autoimmune disorder
other autoimmune disorders such as
multiple sclerosis Hashimoto's
thyroidities asthma eczema rheumatoid
arthritis all of these things has some
to some extent involvement of this th17
subtype
th17 cells are dominant inflammatory
cells that are present in chronic
autoimmune diseases
they produce two major cytokines
interleukin 17 17 F and 17A and
interleukin-22 and each of these
cytokines lead to inflammation of the
epithelia such as intestinal epithelia
or lung epithelia
also these particular tea helper cells
helps to prevent infections of in lungs
and in the intestine
regulatory T cells are the cells that
maintains immune homeostasis so T
regulatory cells are also generated from
th cells by the influence of cytokine
TGF beta and interleukin-2 so Fox P3 is
the master regulator that gets
upregulated and the th T regulatory
sulphate is committed
and the key cytokines that are secreted
by these cells are TGF beta and
interleukin-10
T-Rex cells are marked by the lineage
marker Fox speed 3.
now Fox P3 deletion in charm line
ultimately leads to improper development
of the T-Rex cells on the other hand Fox
P3 over expression in other series for T
Cell lineages convert the fate into a t
regulatory like situation that means Fox
P3 is really important for the T
regulatory cells now let's talk about
some interplay of th subtypes in a
disease scenario
so we'll take the example of Crohn's
Disease Crohn's disease is a disease
where specific part of the intestine
gets inflamed
now in normal situation there is a
balance level of th 17 th1 Cells versus
T regulatory cells so the
pro-inflammatory cytokines and the
anti-inflammatory cytokines are kind of
balanced but this balance gets tilted
when there is a pathogenic invasion of
specific bacteria and in Crohn's disease
there are more th17 and th1 cells
compared to T regulatory cells that
leads to huge inflammatory burst in the
intestine and that leads to the Crohn's
disease
now single cell RNA sequencing has found
that there are involvement of th17 cells
and the reduction of T regulatory cells
in multiple sclerosis patients
now let's talk more about the other half
of the T cells the cytotoxic T cells
which are cold blood Killers so
cytodoxic T cells have cd8 co-receptors
whereas the T helper cell had CD4
co-receptors
so let's question the question is who
activates cytotoxic T cells so when a
cell is let's say infected with virus
then this particular cell expresses of
many of these viral protein
with the help of class 1 MHC
so many of the viral protein mistakenly
gets into the endoplasmic reticulum and
get presented on class 1 MHC molecules
now eventually the class 1 MHC displays
this viral peptide which triggers the
activation of cytotoxic T lymphocytes
cytotoxic T cells are loaded with uh
specific cytotoxic granules which has
granzyme and perforins so granzines and
perforins are secreted these these
particular cytodoxic vesicles lead to
apoptosis so perforin creates pore in
the membrane and granzyme enters the
cell so there are different kind of
interactions between a cyoroxic T cell
and a Target cell there is fast fastling
and mediated interaction there is also
perforin granzai mediated interaction so
once granzyme is inside it leads to the
activation of bead that leads to release
of cytochrome 3 in the cytoplasm
cytochrome C can activate a puff one
which ultimately activates the cleaved
caspase
or which activates inactive caspase 3
into a cleaved form which is active form
of caspase three caspase 3 is the
executor caspase which leads to
apoptosis on other hand there are other
caspases that are activated by fast and
Fast L mediated pathway but the
downstream trigger point is same these
class caspases work in a Cascade to
activate the executor caspase or the
caspase 3.
and ultimately that triggers the events
of apoptosis ultimately the entire cell
dies which is infected by the virus so
the virus gets eliminated in this way
now these cells are really important for
tumor uh
fight against the tumor but before that
let me tell you that there is another
kind of cells known as memory T cells
memory T cells are generally long lived
quiescent but they kind of remembered
the incidence of pathogen exposure as if
they have a complete memory of the
history about the pathogen
in order to understand memory T Cell we
have to understand the phases of T cell
mediated immune response first there is
a recognition phase then there is a
clonal expansion phase where the T cells
are some type of T cells expand in a
clonal fashion then there is a
activation phase where the T cell is
activated or which where it give rise to
plasma Cell Activation and eventually
there is a effector phase where the
cells are destroyed or the pathogen is
eliminated after the elimination of
pathogen so many affected T cells are
not required so they get selectively
eliminated and this is known as a
declining phase eventually many of these
affected T cells would die out of
apoptosis but some of them would remain
and this remaining one would become
memory T cells next time when there is
an infection these cells would show an
augmented response
so let's see
why T cells are necessary generally
after all the infection or the pathogen
is eliminated many of these cells are
dying and some of them are becoming T
cells now T cells some of some of these
are becoming memory T cells memory T
cells and naive T cells are not so
different
so the memory T cells and knife cells
both are in quiescence or g0 phase of
the cell cycle but the memory cells have
a tendency
or they have a less stringent
reactivation criteria so they can get
back to the cell cycle and proliferate
rapidly when it is necessary
so the knife T Cell cannot do that very
quickly until and unless it is activated
by the antigen presenting cell but naive
memory T cell can quickly get activated
with the help of many of these cell
types such as macrophages B cells or
many other antigen presenting cells so
reactivation is quite a quick process
now knife T cells and memory T cells are
very different based on the expression
of distinct receptors co-stimulatory
molecules present on these cell types
such as cd44 series 62 ligand crc7 ccr7
chemokine receptors Etc
now T memory cell display the property
of recirculation
so memory T cells
are of broadly two types effector memory
T cells and Central memory T cells in
this video we are not going to talk
about these subtypes in details if you
want to know more about these cell types
you can watch a different video
now let's say there are let's talk about
the possible models of memory T Cell
generation so naive T cells eventually
go through a effector phase and once the
effector phase is done it becomes a
memory T Cell another hypothesis says
that at each substage there is a
possibility of differentiating into
memory cells so the trajectory is
defined earlier but we don't have an
clear-cut clue about this model so still
it is debatable
now let's talk about exhausted
population of cd8 positive T cells as
the name suggests these are some t cells
which are highly exhausted so we'll talk
about what are exhausted T cells when
they are generated subtypes of exhausted
T cell and why they are important
clinically
exhausted T cells are literally cd8
positive T cells which are very tired
their surface expression is very
different from a normal cd8 hydroxic T
cells and generally they are defined by
the molecular feature of TCF negative
EMS High antibit Low
they have reduced proliferation capacity
and they are cytok kind secretion
capability is much less compared to
normal side cyroxy T Cell so how these
exhaustion takes place it all depends on
the magnitude and the duration of the
overall T Cell response
in general after this
software anti
and his response where there is a naive
stage there is effective stage and there
is a memory formation stage so this is
this is happening in the normal scenario
but when the antigen exposure is chronic
happening over a long period of time
or let's say there is a tumor formation
which is staying there for a long time
in those cases
the naive T cells get activated into the
effector T cells but eventually they get
exhausted and they are proliferative
capacity cytokine secreting capacity
gets reduced and this state is known as
exhausted T cells now exhausted T cells
are really important for cancer like
generally these are the cells which
eliminate tumor
so but the tumor cells are also growing
at a rapid rate so after a point of time
the tumor cells have grown in so much in
number that the T cells are kind of
exhausted to fight them now these T
cells have
eventually become the exhausted cells
sometimes these T cells has no other
options other than becoming the
cytodoxic exhausted T cells
these cytotoxic exhausted T cells are
hypo functional that efficacy has
decreased and this is a major challenge
when it comes to T Cell Therapies
now this is transient state but it is
not good for the overall body's response
but it's kind of like a obligation
when exhausted if the T Cell continues
to fight back it has to die
but another option is to work in a
sub-optimal fit and survive
because exhausted T Cell state is a
reversible State now there are many
negative regulatory modulators which
triggers this kind of exhausted T Cell
State like pd1 PD ligand interaction
ctla interactions this lead to this kind
of exhaustion there are also other
receptors like lag 3 team 3 which lead
to
reduction in proliferation and promoting
a state of kind of exhaustion
now there are persists so few factors
govern this kind of situation persistent
antigen presentation
nature of infection
and then the negative co-stimulatory
signals but let's talk about why it is
so important in case of cancer now let's
say you want the body's immune cell to
eliminate tumor and kill the tumors now
after a point of time if these cells are
exhausted that's not a desirable
situation for your body right
so these days people understood that
negative core stimulation is a key
mechanism to drive exhaustion so in that
case many cancer cells upregulate the
inhibitory Coast stimulatory receptors
and that reduce the potential of the T
Cell therapies that's why these days
people use antibody mediated therapies
where they block the pity ligand or many
other co-stimulatory ligands such that
this inhibitory co-stimulatory action
cannot be triggered
and cytokines can be generated and tumor
cells can effectively be eliminated so
these are very popular therapies these
days so I hope this was useful if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can support us using super
tanks see you in next video
[Music]